my strategy winning big brother canada  is to get everyone to fall in love with  me in the house  and then turn it on week two try and  find my final two maybe a showman  something like that  uh  what kind of personal personalities will  you clash with in the house  the types of personalities that don't  get along with are definitely like  abrasive  people that are extremely entitled uh  rude people  any of those qualities we're going to  have a problem romance or no imagine why  i'm definitely thinking showmance if  it's on the table i'm not gonna go  looking for it but uh if it's there and  she's cool let's rock  um  why is canada  gonna root for me because i'm a likeable  kid you know starting from humble  beginnings uh built myself up and you  know i've been decently successful and  i'm hoping to have that success in the  big brother house so i'm hoping that  they see a bit of themselves  in me